Working fewer hours per week
without reducing our salary.
This is the key proposal
with which PSOE and sumar have closed 1 agreement
to govern together.
What will this reduction in working hours consist of?
From the current 40 hours per week to 38 hours.
and 2nd in 2 024
and 37th and 2nd in 2025,
which would be 2 hours less each day and charging the same.
Moreover,
there is even talk of
to arrive at 30:05 hours at the end of the legislature.
Another key objective
is to continue raising the minimum sagittarius,
which currently stands at €1,080.
This is the most commented measure,
but not the only one.
The pact includes other points
such as extending paid leave by birth,
strengthening the public health system
to reduce waiting lists,
further develop the housing law
to regulate rents
and the increase in the public housing stock by 1-20%,
create a shock plan against youth unemployment,
universalize public education from 0 to 3 years of age
Buy it free of charge
or the gag law.
Although there is still pending,
the main unknown will be
finally invested President.
The investiture is still in the hands of the independentistas
Catagans,
that is to say,
that the controversial amnesty be agreed upon